leave me alone
leave me alone a Georgia woman is
literally carried out of a County board
meeting by police after she refuses to
leave the podium
accident happened on June 10th in
Chatham County Georgia Police responded
after the woman Beth majerone refused to
stop speaking during a Chatham County
Board of Elections meeting
if it gets from my rights for you to ask
me to leave
um body camera video captures the
officer's approach majaroni and asked
her to leave she then yells to the crowd
asking for people to record the
altercation does everybody have this on
film because
leave me alone no
when officers get closer majaroni
anchors herself at the podium sitting
down
it's then that officers physically lift
her up and carry her out of the meeting
yeah
you're hurt me
leave me alone
okay go ahead leave me alone
one safely outside majaroni says she
can't leave until she gets her stuff an
officer offers to retrieve her cell
phone and that's where the video ends
I need my stuff
the Chatham County Police Department
says the county board's presidents
called for majaroni to be removed from
the meeting it was only then that
officers approached her and carried her
out she tried to re-enter the meeting
three more times but officers did not
allow her back inside the incident is
now under review by the Chatham County
Police Department reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie